>> Trace: WELCOME BACK.
WE HAVE A LEGAL DOOZY FOR YOU
TONIGHT ON THE DOCKET.
THE CASE OF A 78-YEAR-OLD
GRANDMOTHER IN ARIZONA WHO IS
SUING HER CITY BECAUSE SHE GOT
ARRESTED FOR -- YOU LISTENING --
FOR SERVING HOT MEALS TO THE
HOMELESS.
NOW LET'S BRING IN THE HOST BUT
THE NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH
PODCAST, BOB BIANCI.
I GOT TO SHOW YOU THIS VIDEO.
THIS IS THE BODY CAM VIDEO OF
THE POLICE OFFICER ACTUALLY
ARRESTING THE 78-YEAR-OLD
GRANDMOTHER AFTER SHE FED THE
HOMELESS.
>> I THINK THIS IS A PR
NIGHTMARE BUT OK.
HERE'S THE BAD NEWS.
>> OH NO.
>> YOU'RE UNDER ARREST.
>> I AM?
>> YES.
>> HA-HA, IT WAS A PR NIGHTMARE
BECAUSE THE GRANDMOTHER WAS
DOING THE GOOD THING.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT ACTUALLY
VIOLATED HER 14TH AMENDMENT.
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT IT?
>> TRACE THIS COP HAD IT RIGHT
DOWN.
HE CALLED SUPERVISORS AND SAID,
YOU ARE SERIOUS?
YOU WANT ME TO ARREST A
76-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WHO WAS TRYING
TO FEED THE POOR?
HE WAS TOLD TO DO IT.
HE LUCKILY DIDN'T PUT HER IN
HANDCUFFS.
NEVERTHELESS THE DID CIVIL
RIGHTS CASES AND A AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR -- THIS LOSS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETS POOR
PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM IF
PEOPLE ARE BEING FED SO LONG AS
IT'S NOT BEING DONE FOR
"CHARITABLE REASONS."
YOU COULDN'T BE ANY CLEARER THIS
IS TO STOP A DEFINED CLASS OF
PEOPLE FROM BEING TAKEN CARE OF.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THEY
ULTIMATELY DISMISSED THIS CASE
AGAINST A WOMAN.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS PURSUANT TO
THE 14TH AMENDMENT, THEY COULD
NOW BE SUED FOR FALSE ALEFT AND
MALICIOUS PROSECUTION.
-- FALSE ARREST AND MALICIOUS
PROSECUTION.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE THROUGH AND
THROUGH.
>> WE CAN SHOW YOU ENDLESS
VIDEOS OF PEOPLE STEALING FROM
CVS AND WALKING OUT AND NEVER
WENT TO JAIL.
>> HERE IS THE VIDEO AFTER THE
WOMAN GOT ARRESTED.
OH!
IT'S A QUOTE!
LET ME QUOTE.
"I JUST FINISHED UP SERVING
APPROXIMATELY 26 OR 27 PEOPLE
AND THE VERY LAST PERSON THAT
CAME THROUGH, I LITERALLY WAS
SCRAPPING THE BOTTOM OF MY PANS,
FINISHED OFF THE FOOD, GAVE HIM,
AND AS HE WAS WALKING AWAY,
THESE TWO POLICE OFFICERS DROVE
UP.
IT IS KIND OF CRAZY."
COULD SHE SUE IN RETURN ON THIS,
BOB?
I GOT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY SHE'S GOING
TO SUE FOR FALSE ARREST AND
MALICIOUS PROSECUTION.
SHE ALREADY HAS.
SHE'S ONLY SEEKING $1 IN
DAMAGES.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT MONEY FOR HER.
SHE'S GOING TO WIN THIS LAWSUIT
EVEN IF SHE LOSES BECAUSE SHE'S
TRYING TO MAKE A POINT.
SHE'LL WIN THIS CASE AND THE LAW
PROBABLY WILL BE THROWN OUT AS
BEING UNCONSTITUTIONAL, TRACE.
>> Trace: NEXT TOPIC, FORDHAM
UNIVERSITY BOOSTER SHOTS, RIGHT?
THEY'RE MANDATING BOOSTER SHOTS
AT FORDHAM.
IT'S CATHOLIC.
IT'S JESUIT.
THEY'RE MANDATING BOOSTER SHOTS.
NO OTHER UNIVERSITY IN ALL OF
NEW YORK STATE IS DOING THIS AND
THEY DID IT AFTER SCHOOL
STARTED, BOB, AFTER THESE KIDS
PAID THEIR TUITION.
THEY'RE LIKE, YOU GOTTA TAKE THE
BOOSTER OR YOU'RE OUT.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> SOME CONFLICT ON THE FACTS
FROM THE REPORTING WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW, TRACE, BUT DEFINITELY ON
THEIR WEBSITE THEY TALK ABOUT
THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE TO FILE
THE CDC -- FOLLOW THE CDC
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS CHANGE AS
THE DISEASE PROGRESSES.
THAT'LL BE THEIR DEFENSE TO THE
CASE.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, THE STUDENTS
HAVE MAYBE A PLAUSIBLE ARGUMENT
AND THE CASES HAVE BEEN PRETTY
MUCH SUPPORTED ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE SUPREME COURT THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
IMPOSE THE MANDATES.
THAT MAY NOT APPLY IF WE CAN
PROVE THE STUDENTS WERE TOLD
THIS IS WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO, WE
DID IT AND NOW YOU CHANGED THE
RULES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GAME.
I THINK IT'LL BE A TOUGH LAWSUIT
FOR THE STUDENTS.
>> Trace: DID FOR THEHAM NOT
GET THE MEM-- DID FORDHAM NOT
GET THE MEMO THE VACCINE DOESN'T
STOP YOU FROM GETTING IT?
THIS APPLIES TO VISITING
ATHLETIC TEAMS.
I'M THINKING, GOOD LUCK WITH
THAT ONE IF NO ONE ELSE IN NEW
YORK IS GOING BY THIS.
>> TRACE, THERE'S THE FAMOUS
SUIT WHERE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS SUED BECAUSE
THEY HAD OSHA MAKING VACCINE
MANDATES FEDERAL.
THE SUPREME COURT SHOT THAT
DOWN.
WHAT THE SUPREME COURT ALSO SAID
IS THIS IS A RIGHT THAT'S
RESERVED FOR THE STATES AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS TO MAKE ON
THEIR OWN AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN'T MANDATE IT SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE RIGHT.
IF THAT IS THEIR OPINION -- BY
THE WAY, THEY'RE FOLLOWING CDC
RECOMMENDATIONS.
NO MATTER IF YOU AGREE WITH
THOSE OR NOT, THEY'RE ON GOOD
FOOTING SAYING WE'RE NOT
ARBITRARILY DOING THIS, THIS IS
WHAT THE C